ah dancing in the middle of World War
one how romantic
these behind jizz okay okay fine then
how do the Amazons dance dance no one
was asking you Steve she just said that
this wasn't dancing why would you teach
her how to dance doesn't you want to
show us what dancing is Right yari said
that like five lines ago so what is it
then
what is dancing no no stop ah stop
kissing you've evolved past that you
already said that in the boat scene come
on Wonder Woman script you use the rule
of threes you set it up is before just
this way you've reinforced it and then
what there's no payoff as no one in this
movie ever written a joke before it's
one of the oldest tricks in the book
that trick is so old
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where I like to
say we're equal opportunity movie
ruiners and on that note today we're
talking Wonder Woman the
highest-grossing DC movie to date and
the one that everyone is saying is the
best whatever the za but hold on to your
invisible airplane there Diana I've got
a few knits to pick with your movie
don't get me wrong a comic book
superhero movie directed by a woman
starring a woman is awesome and long
overdue I don't have any issue with any
of that
my issue is actually with the man of the
movie good old Zack Snyder aka mr. I got
a story by credit for Wonder Woman who
I've taken to task today Zack Zack I'm
gonna level with you now I'm not getting
paid millions to write movies but I do
know a couple of things from watching on
like starting a movie with a flashback
into a photo followed by a flashback
into a history book does not make the
movie the next inception it makes it
pretty heavy on exposition or how about
introducing the marksman and then having
him do nothing I mean seriously nothing
he's given multiple opportunities to
shoot or learn how to shoot or show that
he has any sort of character arc in any
fashion and then just nothing even the
moral of the movie the truth is what you
believe what does that even mean
straight talk Wonder Woman you're gonna
have some trouble defending that
philosophy when Hitler rolls into town
in like 15 years I don't think many
people want the truth to be what he
believes
long story short watching this movie for
as much as I enjoyed it just made me
want to run a channel like cinemasins
every once in a while but what I'm
getting at today isn't about the
philosophy of Wonder Woman or how vague
her power set is or even how a blue silk
dress is able to support a full-on sword
let alone Wonder Woman walking with it
no internet my issue today is one that
is far worse than any of that because it
is so basic that it's unforgivable
even in a totally fictional movie
according to the way this movie is
written Diana and Steve would never have
participated in World War one
they wouldn't have saved armistice deal
and they wouldn't have saved thousands
of lies from Doctor poison in fact
Wonder Woman
have never even made it into the war in
the first place
I know you're thinking it's because of
some magical physics thing or some
existential conflict or it's something
I've completely manufactured for the
purposes of clickbait but it is
literally because their boat was too
slow that's right the entire payoff of
this movie everything after they leave
the island would have never happened
because this would have never made it
from here to London in time don't
believe me well stick around because
we're about to unravel the entire logic
of Wonder Woman because Zak slip and
Snyder failed fourth grade geography
let's do this as a quick recap Steve
Trevor crash lands off the coast of the
Amazon island of the mascara and gets
saved by Diana aka Wonder Woman then the
two of them set sail for England to
deliver dr. poisons secret notebook back
to the British and thus end world war
one huzzah to get on a sailboat they
have a super awkward conversation about
sleeping together because apparently any
humor that revolves around a man and a
woman always has to be about sex and
then they fall asleep after that we have
a different scene that isn't them and
then poof they're pulling right up to
London the next day they have no extra
food or water that we see you never see
a sailing montage and Diana wakes up in
the same position you see her fall
asleep in so we know based on movie
logic that this is supposed to be the
next day and that they made this whole
trip overnight but just where did they
come from
the mascara is unsurprisingly not a real
place but we do have plenty of clues
about where it might be the architecture
on the island looks like ancient Greece
which isn't all that surprising Wonder
Woman's whole origin is based on Greek
mythology we hear about characters like
Zeus and Ares all the time throughout
the movie her whole frame of reference
is built on Greek myths and even her
real-world name and Diana is a reference
to one of the most famous Greek
goddesses so off the bat we know we're
in the general greasy area but that
doesn't help out as much as you might
think
ancient Greece wasn't just the Greece we
see today at its peak Greek territory
extended through the Middle East all the
way to India and south into northern
Africa so at first it seems like the
Mascaro would be impossible to pinpoint
but lucky for us there's something else
that narrows the location way down
Steve's plane remember Steve
in Turkey when he steals the plane that
eventually crashes off the post of the
mascara now he might think that planes
can fly anywhere but that definitely
wasn't the case in World War one
remember this is 1918 the Wright
brothers flew the first plane ever in
just 15 years earlier and they flew it
for literally a hundred and twenty feet
and they were basically hovering ten
feet off the ground
that's not even an exaggeration that's
pretty accurate so flying in a plane
from World War one was basically like
getting into a kite with an engine and
hoping that it wouldn't fall out of the
sky
long story short these things weren't
going too far too fast in this photo
from the movie we can confirm that Steve
is flying in a Fokker e3
Sariah mature Episode a plane from
Germany specifically supplied to Turkey
in World War 1 starting in 1915 and
that's a pretty important detail because
that type of plane had a flight range of
a little over a hundred mile which isn't
gonna be getting him anywhere close to
boating range for London aah
[ __ ]
even the best planes from World War one
couldn't stay in the air on a single
tank of gas for more than three hours at
a time they also didn't fly over 90
miles per hour which means that at best
at absolute best when Steve hits the
drink is absolutely under 300 miles from
where he took off so that begs the
question
where's takeoff again we're not told
exactly where in Turkey the base is but
the two most plausible sites for the
weapons facility would be Istanbul or is
mirror now Steve's not an idiot well
that's kind of up for debate but let's
say that he's not an idiot he knew he
wasn't making it all the way to London
on a tank of gas but he would have known
that he could get to the Allied ships in
the Mediterranean in a couple hundred
miles so best-case scenario again
best-case scenario he's flying out of
Izmir and can make it to about 3 270
miles away the absolute maximum range
that we just calculated for a plane in
World War 1
now Crete obviously isn't famous Kira
because it was on the map and definitely
occupied by not Amazon's back in 1918
but lucky for us there are literally
hundreds of other tiny islands in and
around that area and the ones that
weren't already owned by movie stars
could easily have substituted fruit them
Kirra so to make it easy on ourselves
we'll use this general zone as Steve's
crash point and say well now he has to
go from here to get to London all right
Zach I know it's been tough for you to
keep up with all this geography so far
so here's a nice picture of a duck keep
you interested and here's that duck in a
washed-out color palette and hey let's
add in some explosions here's the sky
beam am i connecting with you now good
because now we get to the good part or I
should say the part that completely
invalidates literally the rest of the
movie because you can't sail from here
all the way around to here over 3000 and
300 miles in one night in 1918 let me
show you what I mean now I'm no Jack
Sparrow savvy but I do know that the
boat you're in has a lot to do with how
fast you sail the boat that Diana and
Steve take is an ancient Greek sailing
vessel but that's bad news right off the
bat for one ancient Greek boats were
ridiculously slow the fastest Greek ship
is the trireme which went 80 to a
hundred kilometers per day and it was a
huge ship and it had 180 men rowing it
if that weren't ridiculous enough Greek
boats weren't even capable of changing
the direction of the sails which means
they had almost no control over their
direction if the wind was blowing the
wrong way which by the way in the
Mediterranean it does all the time
this map shows you that the wind in the
Mediterranean basically just goes around
in little circles which means in all
likelihood Steve and Diana would have
washed up in Italy or literally just
gone around in circles between Egypt and
Greece over and over again because their
freakin boat can't make a right turn you
know how there are all these stories
about Odysseus and all those other
ancient Greeks sailing around for weeks
and washing up on random islands yeah
it's because their boats were basically
glorified driftwood if you keep this
really accurate based on the boat
they're using getting to London would
take a whopping two months let me say
that again
two months we've given this thing the
best-case scenario based on all the
factors that we've considered thus far
this means that the rest of the movie
would have been over for almost six
weeks by the time they just showed up in
the harbor in that circumstance they
might as well just have stayed home and
had Steve discusses above-average space
some more with Amazon's if I want to get
really generous about this we could say
that somehow they have a more modern
sale and can travel up to the speeds of
America's Cup racers which is the oldest
international sailing competition in
history these boats can go up to 34
miles an hour though the fastest one on
record went 55 miles per hour
oh boy slow down they're almost hitting
the speed limit of a two lane state
highway if they're traveling at the
speed of a sailboat in the America's Cup
they'll fare a lot better finishing the
trip in just about four days being still
missing the vast majority of their own
movie and showing up just in time for
dr. poisons plan to gas London to take
effect but even if we give them the
fastest sailboat in recorded history the
bestest sail rocket to at 75 miles an
hour they'd still need about two full
days to go from Crete to that port of
London and that is giving them
advantages that are completely
impossible so is that it have we
disproved this movie yet oh of course
not if the comments section has shown me
anything is that it is literally
impossible for me to do enough research
and approach these topics from enough
angles where all of you are convinced
that I actually do research on these
things but I've already beaten you to
the punch if you're one of the better
commenters who actually do leave
thoughtful evidence against my theory
well you would say hey when they arrived
in London Steve mentions that they got
lucky and hitched a ride from a friendly
tugboat we got lucky we caught a ride we
made some good time oh happy day their
travel problems are solved except not so
fast there Steve and Zack and comment
section
not even your magical tugboat of
impossible travel will save you here
first off tugboats in World War one were
scarce er than you'd think at the
beginning of the war the British Royal
Navy only had seven which they mostly
bought from private tug boaters private
tuggers oh that's dirty professional tug
'yes oh that's worse
tugboat errs it is however you want to
say it the British Navy did build a
couple dozen more tugboats before the
end of the war but the majority of them
were harbor tugboat
meaning that they didn't go out into the
high seas the bigger deep ocean tugboats
weren't even finished until 1919 and the
farthest they went from London was this
area here between England and France
that means at the very most the tugboat
could have pulled them the last 200
miles of their 3,300 miles sail at about
14 knots 14 knots is about 16 miles per
hour or about the speed of an aggressive
twelve-year-old on a bicycle
needless to say Steve may be getting
lucky after that dancing scene but the
tugboat ain't doing nothing for him
trust me Zack I tried I tried to figure
out a way for this one to work for you
through river systems through alternate
pathways through canals that weren't
even built yet through faster boats but
it is time to face the truth the way the
movie is written Diana and Steve would
literally miss the whole rest of their
own plotline as well as the entire rest
of world war 1 Armistice happens while
they're still sailing around dr. poisons
gas reignites tensions and kills
thousands wonder woman doesn't lead a
one-woman charge in a bikini over the
open trenches of Europe or survive a
literal firestorm without singeing a
single hair ares ultimately wins as the
war continues indefinitely and forever
changes the course of history and no
matter how strong and independent
Diana may be not even she can change
real world geography and now you know
the real ending to Wonder Woman Steve
and Diana run out of food and water
after three days because they didn't
pack enough and are forced to land their
boat in Italy after traveling a solid 60
miles and then they spend the rest of
1918 eating pasta and trying to figure
out what the heck Amazonian dancing is
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory
and cuts